to our suffering my dear there's not  enough Scotch in the world for that are  you right now  a little novella I'm calling none of  your goddamn business well you were  invited to stay here for a few days we  can find a place surely it has these  bouts just gone sick in the head I read  your story you do it made me feel  thrillingly horrible do you know what  it's like to have a secret what are you  up to that girl what do you think tried  in a bit trashy but give it a go I like  you Rosie can I trust you I feel like  we're in the Scottish play on the verge  of madness what we'll see their secret  looks  I'm counting down from 3 3 2 1  oh you've done it  what becomes of your dear heroine what  happens to all lost girls  you